so first of all I want to tell you I
don't smoke and number two I don't
recommend smoking and this video I want
to talk about a very specific thing that
it relates to stopping smoking too
suddenly now I highly recommend you do
stop smoking but you have to do it
correctly
because what I've observed with many
many many people that are chronic
smokers and they stop very suddenly they
start gaining weight in the stomach
that's high levels of adrenal hormones
they start having problems with the
heart blood pressure health problems now
a lot of people don't have that problem
but I've observed a lot of people who do
have that problem and it has to do with
nicotine so let's talk about nicotine
nicotine is a drug that triggers certain
body chemicals they're called neuro
transmitters now what is a
neurotransmitter neurotransmitter is a
hormone like chemical that travels to
the nervous system hormones are
chemicals that travel through the blood
so nicotine triggers some
neurotransmitters which have to do with
the stimulation of the adrenal glands
and other body parts okay so we're gonna
talk about the adrenal over time chronic
smokers with a lot of nicotine start to
trigger the adrenals and to the point
where you can feel relaxed when you're
smoking because nicotine opens up or
vasodilate s--
the arteries around the heart - called
the coronary arteries the main arteries
around the heart so you can actually
feel like you can relax when you smoke
it's kind of weird isn't it
and it also relaxes the bronchial tubes
so when you breathe this smoke you can
in you can feel like you can breathe
better with nicotine it's not the smoke
it's the nicotine that opens up the
bronchial tubes and this is all
initially when you start smoking but
over time it becomes a lesser effect so
you need more and more nicotine to
create that effect so people generally
smoke to reduce stress and they can
actually feel calm but what's happening
is just a drug that's manipulating these
certain chemicals giving you the
illusion that you can
that you feel your stress going down
when really it's going up all it's doing
its opening the blood flow to the heart
and it's opening the lungs but creating
a lot of other issues for the rest of
the body now what happens with nicotine
over time is the receptor that receives
that that chemical in the adrenals and
in the brain and other parts of the body
starts to become downgraded or
desensitized or resistant very similar
to if you eat a lot of sugar the
receptors for sugar or insulin will get
downgraded Nicole that insulin
resistance is type 2 diabetes because it
comes from too much sugar well the same
thing with too much nicotine your body
is basically trying to adapt and reject
the nicotine so it's gonna force the
body not to absorb it to some degree so
those receptors for nicotine become
desensitized they won't let it in
so here the body is your adrenal glands
which is the stress gland are so
dependent on that nicotine over time
that if you stop cold turkey with these
receptors being downgraded you like have
a sudden shift of neurotransmitters that
drop way way down because they're so
dependent it's like having a child
that's so dependent on the parents that
parents do everything for this child to
his 20 years old and kicking my house
you can't survive he doesn't have any
skills so the point is nicotine makes
the Drina 'ls dependent on nicotine and
then when you stop the adrenal glands
can crash and burn and create a lot of
health problems all right now I
recommend that you do stop smoking but
do it correctly how do we do this number
one right before you stop smoking and
during the stopping in the smoking and
after the stopping of smoking you need
to replace the raw materials to build up
those neurotransmitters know those
specific ones are phenyl alanine you can
buy these from the health of store
phenyl alanine tyrosine l-dopa those are
the three amino acids that you can get
that will help building up your reserve
so you can make the transition off the
cigarette smoking without creating
serious adrenal issues and weight gain B
vitamins very important because there
are the precursors the thing that help
you bill
up these these neurotransmitters so I
recommend you get your B vitamins from
nutritional yeast not the synthetic ones
you buy toughest or okay so that's this
is the protocol alright so I just want
to summarize the point that if you ever
ask someone when they started gaining
weight many times they'll say well after
I stopped smoking and yes it could have
to do with the eating more but a lot of
times it has to do with the Drina glands
that can't recover from years of the
dependency on that drug hope this helped
I'll see you the next video